good morning believe nation my name is
Evan Carmichael my one word is believe
and I believe that entrepreneurs will
solve all of the major problems of the
world
so today's message is get used to
rejection over to you Jack Ma when I in
the graduate from University and before
you know for three years I tried fill in
the universities so I applied jobs for
thirty times got rejected
I went for a police you know you're not
good I went to you know even the KFC
when KFC came to China birthday party
twenty four people went for the job
twenty three people accepted I was only
a guy and we went for please five people
all of them accepted I was the only guy
deny respectful people so for me being
turned down rejected oh by the way I
told you that I would I apply for
Harvard for ten times rejected I know
you rejects re now in Todd you wrote
them and said I'd like to come to
Harvard yeah and then I told myself some
deaf could go teach their baby so I
never applied to KFC or Harvard or got
rejected from those places but I think
rejection is part of life as an
entrepreneur you were going to get
rejected over and over and over and over
again it's just part of being an
entrepreneur and being a business the
first thing you put out won't be very
good people will hate on it people give
some constructive criticism as well
people will say no because they don't
know you trust you like you and so you
won't get those first deals it takes a
lot of time to build up a business and
make a successful and even when you've
gotten to that point where you're
feeling happy and you're bringing on a
team and building the business you're
still going to get rejected constantly
it's just part of life as an
entrepreneur and so if you can handle
that it's going to be a really hard road
for you to be an entrepreneur I think
the way to get through ejection is two
ways to do it one is use rejection as
fuel kind of like
what Jack Ma did like I got rejected ten
times by Harvard one day I'm going to go
teach there right one day I'm going to
go speak there so use that as shielding
you turn me down I'm going to show you
I'm going to beat it I'm going to come
back and be the teacher they're right
you turn me down for this deal I'm going
to go get it sealed ten times as big
right so that's one you can either you
can use rejection as fuel to help me go
off and do something bigger and in
motivation today I'm going to prove them
wrong the second way is just to forget
about it just get used to it that's more
what I do I don't really use rejection
as fuel doesn't really bother me when
somebody turns me down or when a new
series doesn't work I was trying to
think when I was preparing for this
video what's the recent rejection that I
have because there's been so many but
none really stick out is being super
memorable the one that I came up with
was I tried a new series on the weekend
a while ago about the best of
Kickstarter and it was a new series that
I was testing of showing different
Kickstarter ideas that I thought might
be helpful for you and that video didn't
do as well as I would have liked to do
as well as other videos and we'll
probably going to kill that series but
it's okay I got killed tons of series it
happens all the time on the channel and
I couldn't even tell you all the series
that I've killed because they didn't
perform you guys rejected them it's okay
I just moved past it and so either one
you have two strategies to go for use
the rejection as fuel to see I'm going
to show you how wrong you are and prove
it to them or just forget about it
get used to it it's going to happen it's
just part of the game and you move on I
just think about the next thing that you
can go off the build you do to one of
those strategies but don't get stuck in
the rejection I think that's the most
important part if you get stuck and
you're sitting at home or in your office
like it's never going to work you said
no and you just sit there and you don't
take any kind of action that's where it
really hurts you so the question of a
today is I'm curious how do you deal
with rejection do you use it as fuel you
just forget about it move on do you do
something else that I haven't heard of
yet let me know leave it down in the
comments I'm really excited to find out
I also want to give a quick China to
Caleb Othman Caleb thank you so much for
picking up a copy of my book your one
word
really really means a lot to me and I
hope you're enjoying the read so thank
you guys again for watching I believe in
you I hope you continue to believe in
yourself and whatever your one word is
I'll see you again tomorrow morning for
another shot event
[Music]
let me tell your rejection is the Big
Kahuna no entrepreneurship okay show me
somebody who could take a hit I'll show
you a good entrepreneur as well better a
bit up okay but it's all in how well you
get back up know what I have fun by the
way because if you think about a great
salespeople a couple million dollars a
year somewhere apart in this New York
City which my great salespeople do great
entrepreneurs all business comes from my
manager on business they hire staff
they're entrepreneurs you know what I
found only difference between the
superstars making the looms of gear the
person's barely getting by
the only difference not contact not how
hard they work some people were just as
hard don't make any money right it's how
long they feel sorry for themselves once
they get hit some people could take a
hit and look at the two weeks they're at
their desk they look like they're
working but they're not working mentally
I'm out there the great salespeople take
the hit and then I jump right back up as
though they've been hurt just as much of
the next guy but they work right through
they keep going any time if you have
that skill you should be an entrepreneur
that you'll be paying well for it the
single best thing I do more than
anything else I can do those businesses
for myself so the people of course just
being myself if I fail I fall on my face
let me tell you nobody is better at
pretending I'm not thinking of a quick
cover-up trying to keep moving
and you want to know in that act itself
is getting back up fast you always
stumble onto something good and while
one other thing this is I'm not a
religious person so I was raised so
goddamn religious I don't want ever
think about it again
but I do believe once you put your mind
and going forward on anything it is
almost like a battle cry that goes out
in the universe and the world rallies
around you
just come here for again and again so
they have that kind of good faith that
I'm just getting back up even if I'm
going to get slammed life is fair and is
on the weird way in that way in building
businesses you will be swept up by some
lucky chance it happened to me every
time I got back up a little while later
I wrote a book called The Shining and it
was my third book and I got contractual
rights to write the first draft
screenplay for that and I did do that
and I found out later that Stanley
Kubrick who had got the rights through
one of others had already determined
that he and a lady named Diane Johnson
were going to do the screenplay for The
Shining so they basically my screenplay
went in and they said no this won't do
and then they went on to what they
really wanted to do which was fine I
wasn't angry or upset you're not after a
while you get thousands of rejection
slips before you break through you kind
of get used to that and it's just part
of a game but the thing is you learn you
learn little by little you know yes the
answer is yes
you always get a lot of rejection
anytime you're going to put something
new into the world there's a million
people who will tell you how they've
done it better before or how that's
already been done or how it's not going
to work
and you have to look at those as
motivator it's just like you're going
into acting you can't look at
auditioning as a way of getting a job
you have to look at auditioning at the
top because that's what you're going to
spend the majority of your time building
if you love it getting the job is great
so sure the trickiest thing is
continuing to work and I was very lucky
with Heights that I had Tommy tail
because I had some ones it wasn't me
saying bringing something Friday
bringing something on Friday this is
good this part feels here bringing
another song on Friday every week great
years